oh internet's been waiting for this
before we get started one thing the
sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by squarespace click the
link below get started building your
online presence well first we talk about
a new trailer for a movie that half the
internet things is gonna be epic the
other half thinks is gonna suck let's
all agree
we're curious so this trailer starts out
with superman screaming as he's dying
the death rattle heard round the world
as it'll be called and from there very
zack snyder justice league asked shots
you know any trailer i talk about it's
not a play-by-play of the trailer just
things that stick out in my mind that i
feel like are worth talking about or
anything i can make a cheesy joke about
there's that too but i feel like what is
there to say about this trailer the
things that stand out all right we see
black suit superman and we see in this
trailer what we saw before which is
a series of shots and scenes that are
either
different from the justice league movie
we got showing hey this is a different
experience or they're the same if not
similar scenes but showing that there's
different context to them again showing
that's a different experience and that's
what we have here i mean granted yeah
we see dark side like full-on dark side
and now as always
steppenwolf in this justice league movie
makes the joss whedon step and wolf look
like steppenwolf cosplay i'm not talking
the really sweet cosplay i mean like the
cosplay where you're like oh that's that
character but you know
it doesn't have a studio backing him or
anything he's just a fan made a costume
it's
pretty sweet for a fan made costume it
looks like steppenwolf as a kid
steppenwolf could be like when i was but
a child a lad of 14 years old i was
looking for the mother boxes
steppenwolf now looks like steppenwolf
but he's bigger and has crazy
metal armor and you know what let's just
make spikes and the armor moves like
it's alive like
there's nothing more zack snyder than
steppenwolf there's really nothing more
zack snyder
than this trailer it's a series of
really cool looking shots in a movie
where we know the gist
like even if we're comparing the zack
snyder justice league and the joss
whedon justice league the gist is the
same i mean yeah you have darkseid and
this one didn't before but the gist
remains
bad guys are coming the band has to get
together and they gotta fight the bad
guys gonna be some differences some
elaboration on some of those plot points
especially with
superman coming back but really that's
all zack snyder needs to do is like hey
i'm zack snyder and here's some zack
snyder shots for this justice league
movie i mean granted at the end we have
joker another shot of joker he's wearing
what is he wearing like
police gear swat team gear he's in
batman's dream vision which we see a lot
more of here but he looks different than
that picture we got i mean
he's wearing different clothes he looks
like he's in a different location
entirely so i wonder if this is the only
scene he's going to be in granted how
dreams and visions go he could be
sitting there in his police gear
spitting out we live in a society memes
and the very next scene is in a
different place different location
the conversation continues that's how
dreams and visions go but i will say his
voice is a lot
deeper we live in a society
where honor is a distant memory
it doesn't feel like a bad heath ledger
impersonation that's what i'm trying to
get at here and i'm glad
do your own thing don't don't try to
emulate another joker
and there's at least that i'm glad that
this joker sounds like he got a
p90 pickup in his throat he sounds a
little more growly not gonna lie let me
be honest with you
i'm still kind of holding out for that
jason todd theory you imagine that joker
turns around like i hate all the
strawberry jam
my man batman's like i'm sorry i
couldn't save you
jason i mean i suppose he could do that
because that whole zack snyder universe
doesn't look like it's
even around anymore it's like this movie
happening is more of a professional
courtesy
not necessarily what is canon i suppose
by professional courtesy i mean the
studio was like
i don't know a lot of fans want to see
this maybe we can make a few bucks but
in terms of what he can and cannot do
will or will not do he's not locked into
a box at this point it doesn't feel like
he's locked into some box like all right
we gotta
you know leave room for it to make sense
going forward and joker being in this
movie was
one of the reshoots that they did
recently if you haven't figured out by
now after my last wand division video
my theories are more like oh things that
i think would be cool if he's gonna do
it all the time is now
because what will it matter i don't know
that we're ever gonna see that flash
movie
i feel like this justice league movie is
gonna be our flash movie we're gonna get
the most amount of flash on the big
screen that we'll ever get
in here last movie was also gonna be a
cyborg movie
is that's like dude it's all just kind
of crazy right now
that's my god is that movie ever coming
out so those are my thoughts on this
trailer for zack snyder's justice league
i don't know about you it's something
i'm ready for maybe it'll be great maybe
it'll suck
but like i said before i'm glad he gets
to tell his story i'm glad he gets to
show his justice league movie but i feel
like i'm in a different place now and
i'm in a place where i can appreciate
this movie a lot more coming out now
than i probably would have had this
movie come out like this version of
justice league that had come out
initially when this movie was slated to
come out i mean i've seen the extended
cut of batman vs superman which is a lot
better than the theatrical cut so there
is that also i'm in a different place
when it comes to comic book movies in
general maybe it's because now disney's
grip on the comic book movie industry is
just
it's expanded they've they've bought a
lot more properties on the monopoly
board and they put a lot more hotels up
now dc seems like the underdogs and i
just i root for underdogs is the movie
gonna be style over substance possibly
but i'll say it this way as long as
darkseid's badass and that plot is more
cohesive than the justice league movie
we got before
i'll probably enjoy it i'm not looking
for some modern art masterpiece at this
point i just
want to have a good time with the
justice league and even if it is
style over substance i don't give a [ __ ]
look at this past year pile on top of
that social civility
burning around all of us if zack
snyder's justice league at least
entertains me for four hours i'm cool
with it the trailer was exactly what it
needed to be no more no less a reminder
that
this movie is coming out soon and thank
you once again to the sponsor of this
video this
video is brought to you by squarespace
squarespace sells over 200 top-level
domains so you can find the perfect name
for your website but it's more than that
i said it before i'll say it again i
love the fact that squarespace
is a hub to get your online business
going it has features like the ability
to present videos from youtube vimeo or
animoto on your squarespace site every
design automatically includes a unique
mobile experience that matches the
overall style of your website display
projects and customizable galleries add
password protected pages so you can
share your private work with your
clients so many features so squarespace
offers you a free
trial so get on those freebies then when
you're ready to grow your online
presence
no empire think big folks click the link
below go to squarespace.com
jeremyjohns get 10 off your first
purchase of a website or a domain and
thank you once again to squarespace for
sponsoring this video i do appreciate it
alright so this new trailer for zack
snyder's justice league have you seen it
what did you think about it and do you
think the movie's going to be good
are you looking forward to it is it
going to be style over substance and
would that even bother you if it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you